so here we are again and I'm going to
continue my countdown of top ten
episodes for a Doctor Who going through
the doctors nine ten eleven I already
did nine so now I'm going to move on to
David Tennant the Tenth Doctor I'm like
when I did number nine and Christopher
Eccleston is run this will actually be a
legitimate top ten because the guy had
more than actual ten stories which
brings me to the reminder even though
I'm calling this to top ten episodes
what I'm actually doing is top 10
stories because I consider two parters
to be a single story so with that in
mind number 10 school reunion there's
two major things in addition to David
Tennant and Billie Piper being very good
as usual that put it up over the top and
landed on this list one is Sarah Jane
Smith and the other is mr. Finch the
return of Sarah Jane Smith to this
series really in a lot of ways felt like
it legitimized new Doctor Who this is a
good solid continuation it was a bit
like having Leonard Nimoy show up in the
Star Trek reboot it just added
legitimacy and she was just great to
have there particularly the way that she
kind of had a bit of back and forth with
Rose until eventually they just started
comparing notes on the doctor and sort
of connected a little bit better and
anthony Stewart head as mr. Finch I
loved I've talked about him before he's
one of my favorite one-off villains he's
got a weight and a gravitas and he
really feels like he is the doctors
equal cuz he has that weight to his
words that a lot of villains just don't
have which also shows how good Tennant
was very early on in this role because
this is still pretty early into his run
but he is able to step up to the
inherent weight that anthony Stewart
head is bringing to the proceedings
throwing in k9 on top of that is it's
just icing on the cake number nine the
army of ghosts and doomsday the idea of
having the Cybermen and the Daleks in
the same not only in the same episode
but to bash it out it's one of those
things that makes you wonder why was
this never done before and the way that
it plays out does not disappoint I love
the interaction in the way that these
sorts of villains deal with each other
but also just across the episodes
there's a great bill to this because it
starts out with a little bit of the
mystery aspect going what's the deal
with these ghosts what's going on and
jaci actually gets used in a way where
she doesn't irritate me it's an awesome
introduction to the cult of Skaro and
unfortunately they didn't get used
particularly well when they came back
but I think the concept behind them is
great and their introduction is stellar
I mean just when they show up and the
music kicks in you realize things are so
much worse than I thought they were and
I we were already looking at dealing
with a Cyberman army now we got this oh
boy and then the weight of everything
that happens at the end and again
stellar music backing it up when Rose
gets lost when she's on the other side
of that wall they think they're never
gonna see each other again and I also
really like when they do get that chance
to say goodbye that the doctor does not
say what I think everyone knows he was
going to say and leave you in a place
where if you really don't want to
believe that the doctor was going to say
I love you then you don't have to
believe that it does not force you to
accept that I like that approach to
these sorts of things that would if they
actually said it have been incredibly
divisive amongst fans number three
utopia now I know there are some people
out there who consider this to be the
first part of a three-part story utopia
the sound of drums and the last of the
Timelords
but I do think that even though it ends
on a little bit of a cliffhanger that
utopia stands as a standalone story and
maybe I'm cheating a little bit because
I don't want to tie it to those other
two because that that story doesn't make
this list but there's a lot that I like
about utopia I like the idea of there
actually being an end of time though the
idea of coming right to the brink of
when that's about to happen that's kind
of an interesting idea off the bat and
this last colony of humans being so
impressed with this little species that
just keeps chugging on in the face of
everything but really derek jacobi he is
so good and he's so because he's so
affable he's so let you like him
instantly even before the doctor starts
interacting with him and their chemistry
is stellar
and then to see that turn on a dime when
he opens that watch and he has more mess
in his face when he just does that first
turn to camera then John Simm had in his
entire initial run until he came back
late
and that really does speak to the
strength of the performance cuz you
loved it jana so much and you were there
with him and then just to watch him turn
and go that vicious it was great I
really wish that we could have gotten
more time with him playing that part I
also like the return of Captain Jack
Harkness because Captain Jack Harkness
as dour as he is on Torchwood is always
so much fun here I especially liked it
when Jack is sort of working on the
Africa they are there couplings or
something in the in the room that would
have killed anybody else and the doctors
just talking to them through the wall do
you want to die and Jack's kind of
dancing around the issue it's it's a
great interaction it's a great moment
the build to the reveal and the return
of the master was just so masterfully
executed in this episode and I think
it's a strong episode even before that
happens but that really is what puts it
up and over the top number seven the end
of time
now I mentioned I was not a huge fan of
John Sims initial portrayal of the
master but when he comes back in this
one he works so much better for me
because I think the master in general in
pretty much every car nation except his
original one is Roger Delgado has always
worked best when he's unhinged and
unpredictable so that right off the bat
really strong foundation on this thing
and then we have the return of Wilfred
Mott now if you remember my companions
writing he came in at number two I loved
him and David Tennant
I loved him being with the doctor I
loved him being in the TARDIS I loved
the two of them sitting down and talking
while they're on the spaceship and
looking down on the earth I love will
their chemistry with him being so
physically oh but still being kind of
wily and mischievous but then the doctor
being physically young but just the
weight of age on that contrast is
wonderfully played I was impressed at
how well Bri Donna back but not actually
integrating her into the story that
heavily actually works that shouldn't
work it should have been annoying to
have her back but have or not recover
her memories or everything else it
wasn't it's nice and it's sweet and it's
not a lovely little button at the end of
the episode and then we have the return
of the Time Lords and finding out stuff
that I think most of us were not
prepared to realize that Time Lords
themselves hadn't really become almost
as bad as the Dalek I mean no I'll say
it as bad as the Daleks in terms of what
they were prepared to do and Timothy
Dalton
what a wonderful casting choice to play
Rassilon who is a character who we've
seen before if you're familiar with
older who again I've mentioned this with
a couple of people just wonderful weight
and gravitas to what he does in what he
says and his actions and his words the
way the doctor comes to his end that he
did the big thing and he saved the
universe yet again and there's the knock
though that four knocks and then when he
realizes that he's not going to die
saving the universe he's gonna die
saving one old man because that's who
the doctor is and even though he has it
his little moment of it's not fair I'm
important he still is gonna do what he
needs to do save that person even though
it will cost him his life number six
blink epically awesome
I actually recommend the episode Blake
as being the sort of testing water for
anyone who's like you know all my
friends like Doctor Who I've never tried
it where should I jump in you watch this
episode if there's nothing that makes
you go I want to see more of this world
I want to see more of that character I
want to see what else this thing has to
bring then walk away
don't even bother and I'm not saying
that because blank is the best episode
ever but it is the best sort of in a
vacuum like with no context anyone can
come in and watch this episode and see
how good it is I mean the whole concept
behind the weeping angel is just so
wonderfully freaky and brilliantly
executed and I've always been a fan of
the timey wimey episodes the ones that
really kind of play with the fact that
the doctor is a time traveler which
makes his life a little bit weird
sometimes so I like stories that mess
with that and this one messes with that
very well but in a way that's still
understandable never feels like a cheat
it's an example of using the doctor
himself very sparingly but still feeling
his weight in his employ
is throughout the entire episode and
Sally Sparrow is a great care she's a
wonderful one off character she really
does everything that she needs cuz we
needed her for this story specifically
and she works perfectly this episode
just has pretty much everything that you
love about Doctor Who it's funny
it's tense it's mind-bending in a way
that you can still manage to follow it's
scary it's the whole package and yet
only made number six on that list so we
do have some pretty heavy hitters coming
up going to number five midnight now
I've talked about this episode somewhat
before when I did my top ten one-off
villains and I talked about the midnight
entity I love this thing and I have to
just call it a thing because we still
don't know what it is and I hope we
never ever find out because that's what
makes it terrifying this thing that just
takes over this woman we don't know what
we what it wants we don't know how it
operates we just know that it's winning
the the way this episode ratchets up
tension at steady intervals is just
staggering this thing will have you at
the edge of your seat gripping you no
arms the chair your own knees whatever
your knuckles are gonna be white as this
thing continues and I love that and it's
got a really good supporting cast as
well all the other characters feel
pretty fleshed out as the way they do in
really good Doctor Who episodes because
Doctor Who can have a staggeringly great
supporting cast beyond the Companions
when it's done well and this is
definitely a case where it is done well
intriguing set up tents build up
wonderful execution there's a great
episode number for the girl in the
fireplace yes I can be a sucker I can be
sentimental I like the idea of someone
who just meets the doctor at these white
distant points in her life but at the
same time just gets him I mean the idea
of children meeting the doctor is always
nice I mean I would never want him to
have a child companion I don't think
that would work that would get old very
quick but I love how well and how
quickly sort of children get him even
even a child who's out of time and like
completely should not be in his league
at all they just get him and then adds
course she meets him again in the older
age she's coming to appreciate him on a
whole other level in a whole new way the
clockwork droids are also an interesting
little quirky idea they're not
particularly scary or intimidating but
they look really cool and they do get
the job done and as great as the core
story is and as wonderful as the
chemistry is between the doctor and
Madame de Pompadour I also got to bring
up what goes on between Mickey and Rose
back on ship that works really well too
because Mickey coming onboard the TARDIS
was something I was really skeptical
about when I realized it was going to
happen but it shows the chemistry
between the two of them which i think
was actually really important because
we'd seen Mickey as roses boyfriend for
a while but it never really felt like we
understood why they were together but
you see how much fun the two of them
have how excited they are to explore the
ship on their own you get the feel of
why they ended up together in the first
place and as often is the case with the
more sentimental episodes this is also
quite sad by the end and it you invested
as I know I was when I watch it you are
gonna get a little bit choked up at the
end it's a sweet episode it's a clever
episode the only regret I have I wish
he'd kept the horse now as we get into
this top three I need to say this I had
a horrible horrible time figuring out
the ranking I kept switching them around
going back and forth but I know that
these are my top three and I had to put
them in some kind of order so this is
what its gonna end up being so number
three human nature and the family of
blood this episode basically has a
one-two punch of fantastic elements
going for I mean there's a ton of
fantastics but the big one just being
the doctor is human which again is an
idea that should be dumb this should not
work but is so wonderfully executed cuz
the character of John Smith you feel
like you understand him but he's just
slightly off from how the doctor would
be to really make him intrigue him make
him feel like his own entity and then
the family of blood who made my best
felons ranking when it came to one-time
villains wonderful creepy intriguing
danger
and I also really like the love interest
in this which is honestly a really weird
thing for me to say because I don't like
romantic subplots but here's the thing
it's not a subplot in this it's
absolutely central to the story and to
the conflict that John Smith goes
through and it makes the doctor coming
back have that tinge of melancholy and
you feel a little bit bad about it and
Jessica Hines as Joan Redford is just
wonderful in her chemistry with David
Tennant is fantastic and now even though
I said when you lose John Smith you feel
a little bit back because it does feel
like a death when the doctor comes back
and you realize he's back that is one of
the wonderful all-time triumphant
moments of this show but then at the
same time do almost immediately undercut
it with the way that he punishes the
family of blood for their pursuit of him
it's a dark place and you know it got
paid off further because it got explored
more in some of the later episodes so
moving on to number two
the impossible planet and the Satan
pitch now this one honestly is slightly
a nostalgic choice because the Satan pit
was the first episode of Doctor Who I
ever paid attention to I'm not gonna say
it's the first one I ever saw but the
first one I ever stopped what I was
doing and went huh
this is a high level high stakes Horror
Story which you don't see a lot of
generally for horror stories to work
they need to be very small very intimate
they need to feel like it's happening
sort of right over your shoulder dealing
with huge or implications with things
like the devil generally these horror
stories tend to fall apart cuz they get
a little bit too grand and a little bit
too fancy this one still works I think
as a horror story and it's got that same
quality that I mentioned in midnight
which is that the supporting cast feels
very genuine I was actually really
surprised when I went back and caught up
on this that none of those characters
had been in the series up to that point
because they felt really lived in and
their interaction was great it felt like
the kind of chemistry that characters
would have who've been around each other
for a long time and the music is really
wonderful the music in this episode in
the impossible planet especially is
unlike almost anything else that
Marigold has ever composed for the show
it's just so
when Kali and so lonely it sounds almost
more like music from Firefly you know
the space equivalent of the desert feel
to it that just helps the atmosphere all
the more and the way this thing built I
mean great pacing has been a hallmark of
this top 10 list and again wonderful
pacing to a really excellent climax and
it's hard to pay off a story of where
you confront the devil and have it work
properly and I will grant that once he
gives his hand on the tars it basically
just becomes a magic button that allows
him to save everybody maybe that's the
one reason it does fall short of my top
choice which does bring me to my number
one pick Cylons in the library and the
forest of the Dead now if you have been
following my rankings on Doctor Who this
one should not come as a huge surprise
because first of all I love Donna she is
my favorite companion bonus we've also
got the introduction of dr. River sonic
who I like again I know not everybody
does but I liked River Song and I loved
her introduction again I mentioned
already
I like the timey wimey stories I like
when things happen to the doctor
somewhat out of order and for him to
meet someone who is going to end up
being so important and so vital to his
life and the first time he meets her is
the time that she dies I thought going
back and watching this episode now I do
get choked up not necessarily by the
death itself but I feel her pain and
looking at him and him not recognizing
her I mean it was
I loved this episode when it first air
but it's gotten better as her story has
panned out more since then it's added
extra weight to the story that I already
loved I loved the Vashta Nerada the the
shadows that eat you what a wonderful
concept and once again a supporting cast
with great chemistry that they feel
lived in and they the interactions feel
very genuine and these characters feel
fleshed I don't even though we don't see
a ton of the movie we haven't seen them
before
I love dr. moon I love Colin samithy so
I think he's a wonderful and
underappreciated actor this is just a
wonderful episode I think it's a
fantastic self-contained story
it's got my favorite campaign it's got
the introduction of one of my other
favorite companions great monster
great setting great ideas it's my
personal favorite David Tennant 10th
doctor story but as I said I would not
be shocked at all if other people's top
10 rankings are completely different
than mine in fact I'm sure some of you
have already started writing your angry
comments about why I'm an Indian and
what your ranking is so whatever is your
personal favorite David Tennant doctor
whose story drop it on down in the
comments or give me a top 10 list for a
David Tennant if you feel up for that
whatever it is drop it down in the
comments and let's talk about it until
next time this council is adjourned